towns and highways are under water in
Missouri this morning the Merrimack
River crested overnight much of the
state remains under flood warnings
Michelle Miller is in Eureka that's
outside of st. Louis Michelle good
morning good morning well yesterday
about this time those pumps at this gas
station stood try but after the
Merrimack River crested overnight
breaking an all-time record by half a
foot they're standing at several inches
of water and there's growing concern of
even more flooding as for more inches of
rain or forecasted today a bird's-eye
view shows the extent of the devastating
floods across the state of Missouri
streets seem to disappear into the murky
waters but you all are gonna have to
decide what side of the river you want
to be on more than 200 roads remain
closed including large parts of
interstate 44 seen here submerged under
feet of water this railroad bridge
swallowed up by the rising Merrimack
River collects passing debris instead of
providing passage for trains the st.
Louis County Police Department looks
like it lives on its own Island
it is so beneath the bridge this home
was seen floating down the current river
eventually slamming into a bridge
in downtown Eureka just outside of st.
Louis community members are coming
together to save their city this is our
community living your make up and out
here since I was 13 years old I know on
these people on our back we want to keep
these key to the up and running
volunteers have been working with the
National Guard and even the Coast Guard
to help fill in distribute sandbags so
all of these sandbags with all of this
plastic are keeping the water out of
these businesses they are minimizing the
water intrusion where the pumps on the
other side keep the water from getting
up to the level behind it about ten
miles away in Fenton Darryl Davidson is
hoping the fortress of sandbags
surrounding his mother's home will keep
the water away if the river wins the
river wins but we're gonna try our best
not to let it win this year like it did
last year about 16 months ago rare
December storm swept through these same
river towns causing damage to hundreds
of homes in this system is going to have
a ripple effect through the rest of the
country with severe weather in Texas and
Louisiana tonight Nora all right
Michelle thank you